the final days of this election became
an unexpected Thriller the gap between
the two candidates narrowed and as
voters went to the polling Booth the
result was too close for pundits to
confidently predict
49 year old Nicos Krista dulidis is the
former foreign minister who quit the
ruling VC party just a month ago to run
for the presidency as an independent he
positioned himself as a unifier free
from the constraints of party Allegiance
but his former colleagues on the center
right branded him a traitor who divided
the party
from a position of power the center
right appeared to be imploding
his opponent 66 year old Andreas
mavriamis also ran as an independent
albeit with the backing of the left-wing
Akil party
the AKO government's disastrous handling
of the 2013 financial crisis still
lingers in many voters minds but
mavrianis's campaign gained momentum in
the final week with its focus on
corruption and promise to prioritize the
reunification of the whole island of
Cyprus
wood center-eyed VC voters really
support a left-wing candidate just to
punish Crystal dulidis the answer was no
but the margin of victory was no
landslide
the entry of the new president is a
daunting list of Economic and political
problems inflation hit a four decade
High last year at 10.9 percent the High
Cost of Living provoked a rare general
strike last month over pay demands
un-backed talks between the Greeks
speaking south of Cyprus and the
self-declared Republic in the
turkish-speaking north have been frozen
for nearly six years
and with Asylum Seekers now numbering
some six percent of the South's
population migration is an issue that is
creating significant tensions
there has been a sense in this election
in particular the disaffected voters
were faced with choosing the least worst
candidate
z may have won the ballot but having
alienated so many of his former party
colleagues he now faces a real challenge
to establish his authority
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera